pourquoi parce que j'ai des gens à faire
bouffer ils sont là ils vont aller ou
sinon bah croyez quoi
ouais ils vont peut-être aller jouer à
l'euromillions aller parce
qu'aujourd'hui il aurait peut-être pu y
aller 202 millions d'euros à gagner
alors il ya toujours dans les journaux
il ya des gars qui disent ouais 202
millions et vous pas dire sur les
chaînes d'info tout ça et c'est très
marrant avec 202 millions à 7,60 ball
ligue à ses plus hauts piscine et
accepte ouais c'est même pas mais c'est
mon vélo électrique était de 60 boeing
space dormal bas très bas les dégâts il
ya toujours un mec son excellent info
qu' avec 202 millions on peut à peine
acheté cristiano ronaldo je vais gagner
202 millions d'euros je vais acheter
cristiano ronaldo un mec qui va jongler
dans ma cuisine qui joue on a
franchement qui jouait la foudre je m'en
fous tchad ronaldo du jardin au maître
de la terre partout d'articles devra
gérer ce quinté maintenant c'est quoi ça
les boues pas et j'adore ces histoires
aussi bien des mecs qui disent aussi
ouais tu peux jeter 6 millions de
baguettes de pain macgé pas ouvrir une
brioche dorée quatuor non mais sans rire
et qui souffre au nude subo gagné 202
millions d'euros
déjà première chose ou quitter
l'émission ça c'est la bonne nouvelle
mais aussi esthétique va passer d'un
bonnet b abonnés oui c'est sûr sans
rigoler non mais ho loi qui souffre et
vous bhp meddeb déjà ah ouais bon bah
c'est entre les dettes et les pensions
alimentaires versées au revoir mais la
haine que tu fais ça c'est une maison à
chacun des membres de ma famille après
j'achète une niche avec on est un petit
peu de la même famille et après vous
achetez contraire c'est une île déserte
unités achètent des jeunes île flottante
un ca se mettre ma famille on n'a pas
besoin de mettre des masques et tout on
est en train alors ça c'est devenu le
nouveau délire même le nouveau délire
maintenant avec ce qu vide cia dégâts
ils veulent acheter des îles
mais oui derrière le guen maintenant le
fin du fin c'est tu vois accueille
toujours un mec non s'était acheté une
île en grèce ouais à cichosz c'est à
deux kilomètres c'est une petite île qui
s'appelle ciccio noces écoute c'est
génial tu te balades en pédalo ce c'est
un truc de ouf
mais tant marqué ou pas maintenant il ya
le vrai fin du fin c'est l'acheter nu
genre si les copains de bernard montiel
non mais c'est vrai je suis frais mais
une île est effectivement où je mettrais
surtout pas ma famille mais attention tu
compte pas trop sur toi ça fait ça fait
40 ans que tu travailles pas donc ça
change pas de nom mais c'est une île
écolo je ferais je sais pas je lèverai
mais des vaches de la vérité je garde
touche de ne rien perdre ou tous connaît
bien sûr elle y va acheter tous les
points soleil aux fans ou chercheur
gilles verdez encore le pigeon il va
faire quoi il va acheter
il a acheté il va acheter une étude d'un
institut de beauté à fatou il à faire
quoi
mais ce qui m'a père alors voilà alors s
il vous plaît allez la séquence donc
l'art en hiver je vais offrir des choses
à fatou vous allez on connaît ça fait
des années que tu me déçois pas que ça
marche pas sans rigoler un moment rare
est un peu il ya quelqu'un qui je vais
donner ça va vous étonner c'est moi
ouais merci mais pas seulement écoutez
vous vous donnez tellement à tout le
monde qu'il faut qu'une fois quelqu'un
vous donne je donne la moitié coiffure
c'est vrai je sais tu m'as tu avais
gagné 2,5 millions d'euros celle des 212
[Rires]
des fous ou quoi
qu'est ce que vous faites vous moi j'ai
fait un avion un avion
oui comme ça quand j'ai envie de partir
à marrakech et bien sûr c'est la réunion
passe comme alors pas mal tel cela
malawi madone faire l'actuel aéroport à
malley son délire bon d'ailleurs pas
très écolo si moi je suis très découlent
en ce moment donc je sais que nicolas
hulot et arthus aimons cagnotte si on
vous laisse à mon petit pilote avec
grand plaisir
ben je serai là avec jean-pierre et
toute la famille est inquiète pas pas
mal un avion oui pernikoff pernikoff
pourquoi tu fais pas une cure de
dératisation aux messieurs ya des gars
de dératisation tu devrais faire une
dératisation c'est un mec qui te rendes
d'arcade tu vois qui te rend heureux
d'avoir essayé je vais prendre des cours
il va faire un gros bateaux et d'avions
et où les vraies belles voitures comptes
avec les dates avec ton prof d'histoire
ouais je suis prêt alors qu'est ce qu'un
bateau un gros bateau chemin vite et mes
amis et ma famille alors ce qu'on fait
partie de vos amis oui bien sûr
ça costa di questa n'en avez rien
d'évoquer des rêves comme sa soeur ce
plateau voulais pas faire une nouvelle
boucherie
[Rires]
oui oui de choses déjà je fais le tour
du monde
ouais et je crois que j'en rachète le
club de l'om pour maître rené malleville
président en passant trop content des
beaux projets non mais sympa
vous êtes tous des projets de garde en
tête avec vos 200 millions à bouliac
cotées ont gagné six jeunes ont reçu 100
millions à vous fait courir 200 de
merano avignon et de gbagbo jamais dit
je quitte cette émission raciste c'est
quoi ça c'est quoi c'est un vendredi
soir des choix en temps comme ça les
voitures de sport vous les avez le yacht
vous l'avez le jet privé vous le loup et
tout le temps je sais pas moi qu'est-ce
qu'il vous manque que joue tellement
c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup de choses
entre eau notamment vous la fille de
reginald quoi c'est toujours rêver jean
à regina c'est ça fait cas ouvert une
pizzeria
alors moi j'ai toujours rêvé tient
comédies musicales comme je suis n'en
sera un énorme spectacle genre un vrai
truc emmerdes bon c'est à dire vous
allez prendre l'oseille la comédie
musicale frère depuis depuis les dix
commandements n'y a rien qui a marché
attention une comédie musicale sans
daniel levy c'est comme une omelette
sont alors vous moi non moi je sais déjà
donné mon collège à raison la télé et je
lance la marque de vêtements dignité
franchement si non non non qu'est ce que
c'est que je visais une chemise à deux
donc c'est ma grosse actu du moment
c'est que j'ai fait l'année il à ne
regarder l'animé
vous allez voir demain la miilos tecsys
total va venir vous voir pour vous
donner un recommandé signal oui c'est
quoi je misais ne c'est la grosse
tendance du moment là j'avais à dire je
suis pas vous voyez les tendances mais
nous avons été contactés par un rôdeur
qui m'a proposé ça vous avez été
contacté par un vendeur est oui alors
parce que lui il faut savoir dans toutes
les boutiques de luxe non vous savez
chez vous vous avez papa maman horizon
papa maman pigeon a besoin directement
chez lui d'église on en a vendu il
s'appelle depuis la cua c'est ça un
succès franchement ça c'est un succès
fait cher ça bah oui c'est cher c'est
raisonnable
je peux voir la marque voit la marque
mais c'est raisonnable encore non encore
y est c'est larbi rigoler ce type ça
larbi parti comme il est partout